[Music]
this week on the west block providing a
safe haven for ukrainian refugees in
this dark hour
we are with you canada opens the door
for emergency residents for those
fleeing the war we'll speak with
immigration minister sean fraser
thank you
the ukrainian president appeals to
canada and western allies for a no-fly
zone as nato leaders get set to meet in
brussels for an extraordinary summit
former canadian ambassador to the u.n
alan rock joins us to discuss the limits
of western support
and from a coronation to an actual
contest the crowded conservative
leadership race gets another contestant
today ontario mp scott ageeson tells us
why he's the best pit to lead his party
it's sunday march 20th and this is the
west block
[Music]
hello thank you for joining us i'm david
aiken
more than 3 million ukrainians have fled
the country since the russian invasion
began almost a month ago people have
been streaming into nearby countries
like poland romania moldova all to
escape the fighting since the start of
the war more than 3 300 ukrainian
nationals have come to canada
now canada is easing immigration rules
for ukrainians and allowing temporary
emergency residency of up to three years
joining us now to talk more about this
immigration minister sean fraser joining
us from halifax um i want to first of
all talk about the numbers um we heard
from the canada border services agency
that since hostility started about 3 300
ukrainians have come to canada i know
you've been counting since january 1st
and if you add all that in we're about
9 200 ukrainians here
what is your department planning for in
the context that i think we ended up
with like 73 000 syrian refugees
how many refugees from ukraine
should we be planning to take in
uh first of all thanks very much for
having me david i really appreciate your
willingness to shine a light on what
canada is willing to do to support the
vulnerable ukrainians who are fleeing
ukraine um to answer your question uh
it's hard to predict the precise number
that we should plan for and that's why
we built a program that was designed to
respond to demand rather than a
predetermined allocation as we do with
ordinary refugee resettlement programs
which are typically spread
over many years we needed to be in a
position given the
massive numbers of people who were
flowing out of ukraine to the west to
respond to the the demand that we see
and as the facts change uh the
flexibility that we built in by building
a system that's based on the way that we
welcome visitors to canada allows us to
handle uh significant numbers and the
just to put it into perspective
the system in an ordinary year when it
comes to visitors can process up to a
couple of million people a year
but with respect to ukraine we're seeing
as you mentioned since the 1st of
january more than 9 250 have arrived
already and about that many have applied
again to come under the expedited
process and now that we've launched the
new program this past week we're going
to keep a very close eye on the numbers
to see how many more applications come
in now that we've introduced this new
expedited platform with fewer barriers
barriers to entry the reason i asked how
many candidates it might be planning for
or expecting is because
i'm just wondering how big the the
crisis gets we know the un agency that
tracks this says we're approaching three
and a half million people have left
ukraine and i wonder if you're getting
intelligence from that global scale
could it be five million people leaving
ukraine eight million people i mean
surely the west broadly speaking has to
be able to go do we have the resources
to
house that many people at least
temporarily on the borders of ukraine
uh well realistically uh
there are no certainties when it comes
to war and we need to be prepared to
deal with whatever situation may arise
uh when i think in particular of
countries that border ukraine to the
west that are already seeing millions of
people flow out
there's not a choice as to whether they
can handle the numbers of people the
people are coming regardless of what uh
what those countries would have
the canadian perspective is that we need
to do our part and i want to pick up on
that because our refugee programs for
afghanistan refugees or syrian refugees
i think people understand that those
syrians and afghanistans afghanis have
come to canada they're going to build
their lives here they're not planning to
return or the odds are poor but i think
the the feeling is the ukrainians that
are coming or leaving their country they
hope it's temporary and they're they're
going to be go back home does that
change the way you build the program and
provide resources for ukrainians once
they get here knowing as well too it's
not a lot of men it's going to be women
and children primarily that are coming
that surely means we have to respond
differently for the supports that the
ukrainians need once they get to canada
that's absolutely right and it's
essential that we design a system that's
tailored to the unique circumstances of
the crisis that we're facing now um when
i look at a more typical refugee
resettlement uh process when there seems
to be a protracted need to have uh
refugee camps sometimes led by the
united nations and have the countries of
the world make a contribution to welcome
those people over time and provide
certain kinds of resettlement supports
that will establish a person to have the
rest of their life lived out in canada
uh with respect to the crisis in ukraine
we needed to build a system that had
that flexibility to respond to the
short-term demand but the supports that
are needed may vary greatly one of the
things that we're seeing is the first
influx of people largely already have a
connection to canada whether it's family
members a history of travel to canada
some have employment connections and
that does uh
require a tailored response of course we
have heard as well as you mentioned that
a significant number of the people who
are fleeing ukraine desperately want to
go back they're not leaving by choice
they're leaving because there is a war
ravaging their homeland and they do hope
to return back when it's safe to do so
to be reunited with their families who
are on the front lines there will be
some people who hope to stay in canada
certainly and we're working right now to
develop a family reunification pathway
for people who have family members in
canada now and of course those who make
it to their their way to canada on a
temporary basis will have an opportunity
to apply through our ordinary
immigration streams once they get here
should they wish to convert to permanent
residency i want to use our opportunity
this is the last minute or so to just
get up to speed on the afghanistan
program um i think the number right now
is we've brought around 9 000 afghan
refugees we've committed to taking in 40
000 there may be the perception that
we're your department canada the
government is putting everything it can
into
getting the ukrainians here as quickly
as possible and that's perfectly
appropriate but the feeling is
why didn't we do that with afghan
refugees why couldn't we do what we're
doing with ukrainians to get these
afghans who are stranded in third
countries to our country well i i take
some objection to the uh the
characterization that we were trying to
do uh less somehow for for afghanistan
obviously the circumstances are are very
different on the ground in the immediate
aftermath of the the fall of kabul
thousands of afghans made their way to
canada uh but all of a sudden the
situation became very challenging not
because there was a lack of political
will but because the taliban a listed
terrorist organization under canadian
law has seized control of the territory
there's nearly 10 000 afghan refugees
who've already been approved to canada
that are inside afghanistan today and
don't have safe passage to exit the
country we're working with partners in
the region including some uh who are
working to have a presence to move
people on the ground in afghanistan and
continuing to advance the uh the
resettlement of afghan refugees in
canada the circumstances on the ground
certainly make it more challenging but
our commitment has not wavered one bit
uh we want to make good on our
commitment to resell 40 000 afghan
refugees who will make their permanent
home in canada i was in alberta the last
few days and had an opportunity to meet
with some of the new arrivals some who
had
we had meetings set up with human rights
defenders who've come to canada and
others who i just happened to bump into
on the street and i can tell you the
ones who've made it here now are so
grateful for the new lease on life
they've been given and it
just serves as motivation for me to
continue to welcome afghan refugees as
quickly as possible until we make good
on our commitment to welcome 40 000
afghan refugees including many specific
individuals who helped canada during our
time in afghanistan who are still in
afghanistan today immigration minister
sean frazier thank you so much up next
as russia escalates its assault on
civilian targets in ukraine nato leaders
get ready to meet this week in brussels
we'll talk to former canadian ambassador
to the un alan rock about the need for
diplomacy
[Music]
you're watching the west block on global
[Music]
today
the ukrainian people are defending not
only ukraine
we are fighting for the values of europe
and the world
sacrificing our lives in the name of the
future
and that was the ukrainian president
speaking to the u.s congress voldemort
zolensky is appealing to western allies
directly to step up and do more to help
ukraine nato leaders including prime
minister justin trudeau are meeting on
thursday in brussels for an
extraordinary summit for more on the
diplomatic efforts to end the conflict
very pleased to be joined by former
liberal cabinet minister but more
importantly perhaps former united
nations ambassador alan rock it's great
to see you alan and let's start with
those zelinski speeches to the canadian
parliament the us congress the german
the german parliament remarkable
speeches i thought that he he was not
letting western leaders or the west off
the hook
nor can he i mean he's desperate he's a
remarkable leader
the speeches were so compelling and he
makes a case that it's hard to answer
and what's making us all feel so
desperately frustrated at this point
is the fact that we all want to get in
there and push this bully back across
the border and defend
with zelensky the sovereignty of the
ukraine
but we can't
and the situation's all the more
difficult for two reasons first of all
the security council to which we might
usually look
for some
form of relief is dysfunctional it's
missing in action and the second thing
is the consensus which i which i agree
with
is that if we push putin too far we
might just take a gamble
we could lose and the stakes are too
high a nuclear response is just too big
a risk
so what can we do that's really the
question i don't want to minimize what
we are doing the sanctions are
unprecedented in their strength and
their breadth the military aid we're
providing it pushes the limits uh the
surveillance from the air we're
providing through nato so the ukraines
can ukrainians can know where the
russian russians are in their air force
if there's one more thing i think we can
do and this is on the diplomatic front
david right it's through the united
nations and the general assembly
in the absence of the security council
the general assembly has an important
role to play and i say that if canada
were to form a group of like-minded
countries and enlarge it and work with
allies and build a consensus in the
general assembly for a recommendation
they can't pass a binding resolution
right they can pass a recommendation
that has very large moral force
calling for a peacekeeping group that
would be selected from contributions not
from the us and canada but from
africa from asia hopefully from china
which is a big contributor on the
peacekeeping side you're your successor
at the u.n bob ray our current u.n
ambassador you know he has been on the
record i chatted with him last week
saying
that veto or that we we give putin the
ability to veto and we have to take away
that ability for him to veto
diplomatically militarily and the unga
the general assembly would be the spot
that you can start to reduce russia's
veto at the unsc yes and i think it's
time to get more specific about that and
i think a recommendation for the
creation of humanitarian corridors which
the international committee the red
cross is working on even now
together with a peacekeeping force to
enforce it and protect people
and and if we can get china to
contribute to that it'd be a wonderful
coup but have a presence on the ground
that'll make us feel at least we're
doing something to provide protection to
those who are so very vulnerable without
provoking uh nuclear response
i'm curious about from sort of the
diplomatically uh sort of your
diplomatic experience the u.s president
last week called the russian president a
war criminal i mean he was unequivocal
about that many commentators have and i
think it's pretty clear there's crimes
against humanity happening here what
does that have an effect when the u.s
president is saying to the russian guy
you're a war criminal well i for one was
delighted to hear it because the fact of
the matter is he is a war criminal it's
a crime to cross that border with his
army it's a crime to target civilians
let alone maternity wards and hospitals
it's a crime to unleash your military
against people who are not combatants or
fighters
he is a war criminal and let's let's put
that on the table and let's mobilize
international public opinion against
this guy
and by the way i think the key in all of
this is going to be china turkey's
important as well but china i think is
wavering we saw last week some news
stories out of china that they were very
reluctant
to lend enthusiastic support to some of
the things putin's been doing they've
now stopped exporting certain parts to
to russia
i think that xi jinping is looking at
the international response to this and
wondering whether he wants to be
associated with a pariah
um just for our last question i wonder
about canada's role i heard foreign
affairs minister melanojee melanie jolie
last week talk about our role as being
able to convene people to bring people
together we've already obviously taken a
side in this conflict where do you see
canada particularly looking forward to
the nato meeting this week i know she
was criticized in some quarters for what
she said but you know i think in we have
to admit we're not a military superpower
our influence in this world does not
come from our military no matter how
much we spend the fact is our influence
in this world our reputation at the
united nations is for the ability to
bring people together find common ground
yes
convene and that's what i think we
should do now in the general assembly
let's bring those 141 countries together
again with a strong recommendation to
establish a peacekeeping group to patrol
safe and humanitarian areas as a first
step toward protecting the population of
ukraine and at nato trudeau is off there
on thursday where do you see nato then
fitting in well i think they're going to
have this very discussion i think
they're also going to be talking about
how far they can go without provoking
the bear what about these migs in poland
are they needed in the defense of
ukraine and if they were to be sent
would that cross a line in putin's mind
that would result in a reprisal i think
they're going to be talking about a
whole range of things how far can we go
to assist ukraine these next couple of
weeks are crucial david if ukraine can
survive these next two weeks with the
weakening russian force and the growing
public sentiment
against russia
i think the dynamics of a negotiation
could be very different so we've got to
get through these next two weeks yeah
let's cross our fingers alan rock good
to see you again thank you so much for
joining us really appreciate pleasure
thank you david all right well up next
ontario mp scott acheson is the new name
in the conservative leadership he's
launching today and we'll ask him why he
believes he should lead the conservative
party he's up right after this break
[Music]
you're watching the west block on global
[Music]
now at one point in the conservative
leadership race many in the party
thought it would amount to a coronation
for ontario mp pierre polyev but it is
turning into more of a contest and more
of a crowded contest than many thought
and today one more contestant gets into
the race his name is scott hsn he is a
two-term mp for the ontario cottage
country riding at perry sound muskoka
and scott joins me now from huntsville
ontario the town of course where scott
was mayor before entering federal
politics in 2019. scott welcome to the
program let's jump in right away with
the first question which i'm sure you're
going gonna get asked a lot why why
should conservatives pick you to be
leader well let me first say thank you
david for having me on the program it's
uh great to be here but
i think that people should choose me
because they recognize that the ottawa
is not working uh it's a divisive and
and the rhetoric
it's all about division in ottawa and i
think canadians have had enough of that
and
i think they're ready for a new approach
your party had in the last few weeks in
the house of commons um has made quite a
point of noting that the prime minister
justin trudeau the leader of the liberal
party has been contributing that to that
division um making it very personal
demonizing the trucker convoy etc but
there is a candidate in the race and i
just mentioned him pierre poliev who has
made himself very popular by doing just
that against his opponents demonizing
the prime minister people on the left
who disagree with him so that to me says
you disagree with the tone of mr
paulieb's politics i disagree with the
tone of our federal politics for the
last several years actually i think you
know both parties are guilty of uh using
division and differences of opinion
amongst canadians to divide us whether
it's difference of opinion or
differences of where we live east versus
west urban versus rural there's no
shortage of it on all sides of the aisle
and i think the canadians have had
enough of it i think it's actually
tearing our country apart
i have years of experience in municipal
politics where we build consensus we
work together and we bring people
together and that's what i think our
country needs it's what i offer
and i'm looking forward to crisscrossing
the country and and presenting myself as
the option to bring not just
conservatives together but to bring our
country together um let me just talk
about that that idea of municipal
politics um i used to cover small
councils i covered one near yours down
in ireland at one point in time it's
non-partisan people work by consensus
but there's another candidate in this
race his name's patrick brown he's a big
city mayor and he's one in a city
brampton where all five seats are
liberal seats um why wouldn't patrick
brown's candidacy be suitable as
somebody who might be bringing people
together
well i just think that we need someone
that can appeal to people across this
country and i think it's important to
appeal to people in the gta absolutely
but we need candidates that can appeal
to people literally across this country
i think i offer that
and i'm i'm looking forward to having a
great discussion and great debates with
all the candidates including mr brown
it seems to me there's been a sort of
purity test if you will
that some candidates want to put forward
and that being where do you stand on the
carbon tax and then maybe the other one
would be where do you stand on gun
control i wonder if you just give us a
quick snapshot of as people try to slot
you in a little bit where are you on the
carbon tax and and where's your stance
on on our current gun control
well i think that uh a purity test is
kind of a silly thing and i think the
labels are kind of silly as well i think
it's important for us to be principled
conservatives uh i am opposed to a
carbon tax but not for the reasons that
maybe people might think it's not
because i just think it's politically
expedient and it's not because i don't
believe that climate change is a real
serious threat i just
fundamentally i represent people in this
area that can't afford to put food on
the table and heat their homes and so
it's an added expense that canadians
can't afford particularly the most
vulnerable in our society
and i just think that we need to be
talking about these issues with it from
a conservative perspective and be
consistent in our message uh honest with
each other and stay true to our word
and on gun control that came up as you
know in the last election there was a
flip-flop in mid-campaign for better for
worse and if you talk to liberals that's
when they got wind in their sails what
about gun control if the liberals try to
wedge you guys again on the issues of
assault style weapons etc i know you're
a largely rural riding and there's going
to be a lot of hunters and farmers in
your ridings that
that you represent so where are you on
the gun control issue
well i think it's another classic
example of a liberal government that
looks to demonize a smaller group of
canadians to appease a larger group
law-abiding firearms honors are among
the most responsible people in our
society and
there's no question we need to deal with
rising gun violence in in some of the
larger urban centers but you know we
know from chiefs of police and uh and
from and from boots on the ground that
the these these guns that are being used
in these uh these heinous crimes are
generally guns that are smuggled from
across the border we need to invest more
in protecting our borders we need to
invest more and lifting up the people
that are struggling to get you know out
of these communities that are that are
struggling we we need to we need to
provide hope for young people when a
young person finds that the only hope
they have is to join a gang
then we failed that young person and we
need to do more to invest in in the
programs that are going to lift people
out of those circumstances and stop
demonizing law-abiding firearms owners
in the 40-odd seats in the greater
montreal area 40 seats i should point
out that's more than the seats in
saskatchewan or more than the number of
seats in alberta a conservative party
hasn't won a seat there since 1988 and
that was when brian mulroney won with a
guy named jean-charade at his elbow how
do conservatives
win seats in a big urban area like
montreal or an urban area like toronto
where conservatives have not had any
success really since stephen harper's
majority how do conservatives connect in
our big urban cores in
outside of alberta and saskatchewan
well i think our miss our message has to
be consistent i think we have to
demonstrate that we as conservatives we
can we can be trusted that we have the
character and the not just the policies
but the character and and the courage to
stick to our convictions and and to
speak to the folks that live in in these
suburban and urban ridings uh and make
sure that we're addressing the concerns
that they have as well and and i think
that
the only way the only way we can do that
is by being united as a party and making
sure that our message is clear and
consistent and engaging with every
community across this country
scott agentson is the mp for perry sound
muskoka elected first in 2019 re-elected
in 2021 hoping to lead his party into
the next general election scott thank
you so much and good luck with the race
thanks david
that is our show for today thank you for
watching we'll see you back here next
next sunday for the west block i'm david
aiken
[Music]
you